(crowd cheers and applauds)
- I love you guys.
You got queso!
- But it's so heavy that
my, I was like, hold on.
My biceps are shaking.
- No. She was shaking out there.
- Shaking!
- This is true Texas girl though,
because this is a vat of queso.
I love it. I'm gonna try it.
- Jenna made it. Jenna made it.
- You made it?
- It's her own personal recipe.
- Okay.
- Mmm Hmm.
- I don't wanna reveal
where you can find it, but
if you get Velveeta and you turn it over
on the back, that's the spot.
- Y'all know Velveeta and Rotel
- And Rotel.
- [Jenna] Right?
- That's Texas.
- [Seth] And this is a
single serving in Texas?
- It is.
- [Kelly] Yes, it is. Yep.
- And you could do it for a family of four
if your kids don't eat very much.
- Very good.
- Well, what's great
is you just reheat it.
- [Jenna] Micro.
- I'm all about that.
- Yeah, that's right.
- Me too.
- By the way! Welcome. Welcome to 30 Rock.
- Thank you.
- It's gonna be so fun.
- I love it.
- We've been waiting for you.
You fit here.
Like a puzzle piece.
- [Kelly] Oh, thank you.
- We're gonna be looking for you
in the elevators and everywhere around.
- I know. And thank you for
being a part of the opening.
- It was so cool.
- It was so fun. It was really fun.
- Oh my God.
I love you guys so much.
So wait, do you, do you love your doorman?
Do you know your doorman really well?
- Yeah. Well we have,
we, CJ is a legend and
in fact, I have more pictures...
(audience cheers)
- With CJ in front of the
Rockefeller Christmas tree
than my husband.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Wait what?
- Oh yeah, because CJ's here every day.
- Yeah.
- And I bring my kids, and
CJ and I are standing there
and he's the best.
- [Hoda] CJ is THAT guy.
(audience cheers)
- [Hoda] CJ's that guy.
When we bring our kids
here, because that's like a
a field trip that happens
once a month or whatever.
- Yeah.
- The first person they ask about is CJ.
- Yes.
- Like "Is CJ here?" He's that guy.
- That's so beautiful to
represent that kind of consistency
for kids, too. Like you know?
- Yeah. Really cool.
- And tell me when your kids
come and I'll bring mine. Okay.
- Yes.
- I keep promising play dates.
I promise it'll happen give me a minute.
So I heard that you just recently
visited your high school.
Is this right?
You went back to your high
school? With your siblings?
- Yeah. My brother, my
sister and I went back
to Fort Hunt High School
in Alexandria, Virginia.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you know when you roll up, it was
for all the grades.
So we rolled up and that
was my little daughter
Hope who was there, who came too.
- [audience] Awwwww.
- And it was, I gotta tell
you, Kelly, it was one
of the funnest things
I've done in a while.
And I was one of those
kids who never got asked
out on any dates ever.
- [Kelly] Really?
- I, I went through high
school like it was like
I was like the weird kid, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I had the stop sign glasses.
- I was odd too, yeah I had them.
- Weird. Anyway, except for one kid,
asked me to go to a dance.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And his name was Pete Samuelson.
- Oh, you remember the
full name? I love it.
- Girl! I rolled up and do
you know who walked up to me?
- No way.
- Cute as a button with his
wife, wearing flip flops.
And I looked at, I was like,
there you, that's the guy.
And it was just the, it
was just super sweet.
- That's super cool.
Like the nostalgic memories too.
And like what a sweet thing
for you to say to him like
"Look you like made that happen
for me!" "I felt so special
when you asked me!"
- "You were the only one!" Yeah.
- Yeah. That's so cool. Oh my gosh.
- It was really cool.
- What about your high school experience?
Do you have any fun ones?
- Well...
- Yours must have been, that's hard.
- No, I was, high school
was a little was normal.
I went to Austin High School in Austin.
- Okay. Okay.
- And it was so much fun.
It was like Friday night lights, you know.
But I will say my senior year
you know how you get the superlatives?
- [Hoda] Yeah.
- My boyfriend was most likely
to be on the cover of 'GQ.'
- [Kelly] Congratulations.
- My twin sister, who we don't really
look alike, was most likely
to be on the cover of 'Vogue.'
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was most likely to trip across the
stage at graduation.
(laughter)
- And then when I, you know
drank a little early when I
shouldn't have, people were like "It was
'cause she was drunk!" "She was drunk!"
(laughter)
I was like, no y'all, I was a klutz.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh. Just
not graceful. Me neither.
- [Jenna] Just not graceful.
- I know.
- What specific superlatives.
- I know right?
- Yeah.
- I was like mom and
dad, aren't you so proud?
- What was your
superlative in high school?
- Talented.
- I think I got most talented
or something like that.
Yeah. I got, I got, which
it was the only thing really
that I was a complete wallflower.
Like nobody knew who I was
until I started singing.
And then they're like,
you're the girl that sings.
And I was like, yeah,
I mean I've been here
for a minute, but sure.
- You were a wallflower?
- Which just sounds so crazy.
- Oh my God. I was very shy.
I was very, no, but I think
this is very true and like
for anybody that has
kids, it's so important to
get them involved in things and
let, let them find something
that they feel special, unique at.
I love because when I found
singing I completely changed.
- [Hoda] Yeah.
- My personality changed. I was very shy.
I know you think I'm
lying but I, I was and
and I think all shy kids
are kind of have this little
you know, you know, person
inside that wants to get out
and be an extrovert but you
just don't have the opportunity.
You don't feel comfortable
enough or confident yet.
But yeah, I got most talented I think.
- Arts are so important,
right? Art education.
- Did you get a superlative?
- I did, I did get best sense of humor.
- Oh! Well that works.
- And then we also had class
clown, but I didn't get that.
I was the guy who sat in
the way back and was like,
"Look at this clown."
- [Kelly] Yeah. You were
making fun of the class clown.
- I made fun of the clown. Yeah.
- Yeah. You were a level
up. I get it. I get it.
We have to do another
commercial break everybody.
'Today with Hoda and Jenna'
airs weekdays on N B C.
Up next we've got a game,
Jenna and Hoda versus Seth and me.
- We're taking you down!
- Totally gonna win! It's
a 30 Rock showdown y'all!
We'll be right back.